the girag an experience we had your man
period lately know what I have this
theory that when we shit then it's all
bloody in there that it's possible that
he does at the same time like it's based
on the moon how often you got shit when
you blow your shit happens happens every
couple months it goes for like a week
yeah I living week yeah almost week
existed a hemorrhoid thing oh yeah oh my
god and then you wipe and you just like
Bob still wiping a lot should be like no
just soaking red blood that's all
there's no shit died on your hand and I
can go straight through the toilet paper
and you guys both need to go to a doctor
together and find out what aliens are
raping you in the middle of shit study
and imagine gonna do a fucking camera
over your bed that's a really watch
aliens come in the room and take you
through the walls the middle the night
return you later it's sometimes when you
stand up at your toilet seat looks like
Dexter like it like like the blood spots
that you know didn't go in the water
yeah you're too low Alan and if you guys
are bullshitting out that much blood
yeah oh yeah I mean it poor it pours out
its little warmth it's like a warm Fox
okay I always take a beaker and turn it
over real thin beaker and turn it over
like about that amount this is not any
overt I tell you if the shot girls those
how much water not something to be proud
of you guys are both clearly said Jamie
you okay were there a you and I in the
same boat I can tell you this though I
did have a massive diarrhea problem last
week it was really worse diarrhea
problem i from long time I do not
multiple days or one diarrhea in
multiple days rather low if it was a
stomach cold I don't know if it was
something that I ate that didn't agree
with me but it was like one day I had a
headache and my my head was like wow I
feel so I think it's like a food
poisoning issue cuz I had a headache and
I was like man I feel weak it was the
Hannibal no definitely not definitely
for them yeah it was um no it was post
ham but I hadn't eaten a ham for days
what it definitely wasn't that it was
something that it had I think that day
or before that day anything diarrhea oh
my goodness me it was more than a week
after I'd eaten a ham now that I think
about it did you mix it with the regular
dump and have like a no food it was just
over this is what happened and
whatever was going on inside my stomach
was converting everything I ate into
this liquid and I didn't even make sense
was like defying physics how solidified
was it it was water if you dropped it on
a an incline table at a 40 degree
incline would it go straight off the
table it would take a minute it would
ride like a fucking great wave straight
through a great Brown wave of
destruction dude it would Rumble my
stomach would Rumble and then I would go
oh shit and I'd have really bathroom
then I'd get to and I would hold it
commercials like listen I wouldn't
there's no way I was brave enough to
fart there was no way
there was no way because I would get
into that tub or get it out of the bowl
rather and it was just here whoosh just
just just water tub shooting out of my
ass one complete water for like two days
and then it became like very
untrustworthy shit
like I feel so solid it's worth day yeah
and I got hemorrhoids I had to go get
preparation-h oh no like squeezing it
and pushing it trying to get it to come
out so long which is really bad pushed
air bubbles into your asshole well I
think just squeezing your ass like that
trying to poop is very bad for you
you're not supposed to do that and
that's apparently one of the things that
causes hemorrhoids long dumps so then
but that preparation-h is a motherfucker
do because one day of that cleared it
right up really really yes get the
cooling lake or ranch one or the Grayson
age for Cool Ranch cents
you smell refreshing find out people
like putting it on food you can't eat
that sir it's just like it preparation H
R imagine preparation H was totally
edible yeah
whatever it does it really works good at
a good fixing any sort of a hemorrhoid
situation you got down there that went
away like within a day but man for
fucking days four days of totally
untrustworthy shits drip the pasty shit
where it's like you could spread it on
brick oh I could spread any stuff yeah
it was like leaves in there and shit
because I still eat healthy but it was
like a lot of liquid it was some sort of
a stomach bug whatever it was I don't
have any idea where it came from food or
whether it came from just catching a
cold and
that this cold manifests itself as a
stomach bug but whatever it was man it
was crazy for a few day and I felt real
weak like I'd go to pull my bow back you
know and it was like kind of difficult
to pull the bow back cuz you're weak
from something yeah people use it does
not matter I was weak I was weak like I
would like pick things out having yeah I
could feel it a reference yeah yeah
definitely dehydrated but also just I
wasn't eating right like I was scared no
I wasn't getting hungry either I mean I
was eating right in that I was like
having like lettuce and salads and stuff
like that but I wasn't eating very much
I was eating like like light meals
during the day because my stomach was so
untrustworthy that when that happens
diarrhea what is it what's happening I
don't know man but whatever was like
it's adjusting it's just too much
I would eat like a stay I would have
steak and some salad and it would turn
into water like had a steak in this
salad we become I mean my body was
liquefying it and it would come out just
whoa what is that that's is it too much
stomach acid that just breaking down
everything and no question I don't know
though the the process I should probably
know that you should shit on your hand a
little bit sort of smelled of I fancy it
was that well I took some on it enzymes
on it enzyme it's all been a digestion
on it that's how it got me out of it god
no I just had to do the time I just had
to let my body process it I'll just
drink a lot of water but in the reps
yeah I was I was definitely thinking
that I was probably getting dehydrated
from I was like so much water's coming
out of my ass I got better make sure I
just drink a lot go with it alright does
your hemorrhoid when it happens is do
you even feel the hair mark exactly I
still feel like I feel like it's like oh
I still have there's still some stuff I
got a wipeout really like oh it's just
not just my ass you mind just my bleeds
like a whale it's like a giant turd
that's just my ass now alright that's a
look nice shirt it feels like what leads
out it doesn't even feel anything it
just that's that whale that exploded
yours insider isn't it anyway inside of
me feeling mines mines on the bridge
there a diet that you can take like sir
so yeah it stops that from happen I
promise top line Android it's finding
foods
beating broken jacks any things that
lodge up inside your anal binding foods
and stay away from them or eat a lot of
them I forget what it is oh well you
should probably know yeah it's one of
those two so rice is in that group
binding foodie or day away from them or
keep eat a lot of them mm-hmm I don't
really go by the regimen but if you do
that it would help prevent hemorrhoids
um yes that's my dog Stone when I got it
and now I'm at the 19 do you need a lot
of salad research um yeah yeah does that
help at all I know I feel like it makes
me shit more often yeah but if you if
you doesn't come out like we need a lot
of salads comes out real easy whoo oh
right yeah that's I guess the scraping
mmm pushing I used to pray it was so
jagged it'd be so jagged q claim that I
pray to have it come out because it
hurts so bad oh that's horrible that was
just so inflamed in there cuz I just
wasn't dumped because I knew would be
bad so I was like let me hold it for
another few days oh my god days of
dumping we get compact you held that you
held off from days week at a time that's
interested every week do you that is so
insane that's so insane yeah I've never
even heard that's toxic I guess so
for sure you're containing all that
stuff in your body it's supposed to be
evacuated well it's in that spot
whatever that spot is not rubber if I
can fill it up Tom but if we become too
big for my ass oh Jesus Christ
separated it's like your first time no
no that's your first time doing anal you
pluck mandingo it's like that's pretty
much it was my Soyuz the asshole and it
was probably all dried up in there I
ride up oh yeah yeah peace jagged
cha'aka tearing you apart as shit I
would have to reach in sometimes in
terror Oh
breaking my F door um had to get off
castrated I Adam yeah Johnny I his balls
removed because two things one he had an
inflated prostate that was pressing up
against his colon and it was making him
constipated and he was in the in the
hospital for over a week I had to bring
him in and they had to try to figure out
how to get him to defecate because his
defecation it was back down Wow and then
they found out the defecation was backed
up because he was like he will that go
to defecate but
they wouldn't he would get on his like
friend over at Crouch but he couldn't
poop I knew there's something wrong so I
brought him in and they found out that
it was his prostate was enlarged and you
know he's an older male dog he's like
seven now and so I got him fixed
so they take his testicles away which
makes the prostate decrease too and then
it get over them to shut it out yeah I
used to know but some people say that
you know you should you should get a dog
fixed and it's like it's healthier and
happier for the dog but I had a
veterinarian didn't agree with that at
all he said it's totally natural for
that animal to have its testicles he
goes if the dog is if you you don't want
them to breed and there's a female
around get the female fixed and he goes
and if you want to get the dog fixed you
can but you don't have to get the dog
fixed and he's like if you're not you
talk to making your dog a dad like
forcing your dog have to breed and make
unwanted puppies if you're not being
irresponsible with the dog's sexuality
like you don't have to get the dog fair
can you just get it up a sec to me what
if it cut the balls off let it's the
fuck doggie condoms yeah because you
don't want that type of dark condoms you
don't want that swelling it's the
swelling that comes from the the
testicles and the the enlargement of the
prostate that happens as they get older
and that can be alleviated by castrating
the dog so do people get that I don't
know I'm sure they do humans were like
I'm done fucking 72 you know just come
at that come on balls off I'm sure
people do I'm sure there's people who've
done that I'm sure these people have
just been tired of being a prisoner to
their cock and balls
you just said okay you son of a bitch
you run me for the last time I'd hold
them in your hands for sure people had
done that cut your own balls off oh yeah
you
[Music]